[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Michael core backer Director Google
Cloud Germany Austria and Switzerland
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hats which will come welcome to Munich
first Google cloud summit the future of
cloud is now it is not a question of if
it's a question of when and when is now
I have been a longtime believer in cloud
technologies
I'd probably date that back to the late
90s at that time I was working for a
company called Compaq computers and some
of you might remember that brand which
was then acquired by ulid packer at that
time I was privileged I was based in the
south of France and my job was to launch
what was called back then an ASP
competence center a ASP stood for
application service providers which was
the early form of what we call software
as a service or SAS competence center
today and I was privileged because that
place was located somewhere between nice
and comes somewhere in the hills in a
place called Sophia Antipolis
and the French used to refer to Sophia
Antipolis
as the Silicon Valley of Europe while I
was doing that launching this competence
center there were some smart people
thousands of miles on the West in the
real Silicon Valley busy doing something
else because they were busy Sergey Brin
and Larry Page launched in Google now do
not want to compare efforts and I do not
want to compare results but I would say
some of the ideas that we had around
utility
computing and server on-demand pectin
probably made it somewhere into the
cloud of today for sure what I have
taken forward is the passion for cloud
and I'm quite sure it's this passion for
cloud that has brought me here today
my name is michael korvac ER and I'm
running Google's cloud business for
Germany Austria and Switzerland now the
time has not stood still and Google has
progressed and we have progressed and if
we look at from what happened something
like 19 years ago in a garage in the
Silicon Valley where people started
pulling together infrastructure held
together with legal blocks we're now
looking at an infrastructure we're
running numerous services that have on a
regular basis more than a billion users
think about Gmail think about YouTube
think about search think about Maps
think about play Android and so on what
an infrastructure it takes and all that
based on an idea and a mission that I
would call rather ambitious a mission
that said in a simple form well we're
gonna we're gonna take the internet
we're gonna index the Internet we let
people search that index and we give
them relevant answers to their searches
no matter where they are on the planet
ideally within milliseconds mmm that was
a big ambition when you think about it
to organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful that's a very big ambition when
you think about how the internet evolved
and how the internet grew
to make that happen there was probably
not a lot of off-the-shelf products that
would make this mission come true
think about it what file system could
actually manage that volume of data that
you would create what networking gear
could actually handle all this bandwidth
required what product would I use to
search this amount of unstructured data
and give people replies within
milliseconds how do i scale how do i
scale out and how do i improve my
results using technologies like machine
learning or artificial intelligence so
when looking at this to get to where we
are today one of the requirements was to
drive constant innovation to explore a
path that nobody has gone before and
that led to the development of things
like the Google file system when we're
talking about bigquery how do we search
large amounts of unstructured data when
we think about developments such as
kubernetes container based technologies
how do we distribute workloads across
servers data centers clouds as well as
making machine learning more accessible
and artificial intelligence more
accessible through frameworks like
tensor flow now the great news is in
necessity of fulfilling our mission
we've created all this innovation and
we've given it back to the open source
community and now we're taking all this
the infrastructure that serves billions
and the tools that run Google and we're
making this available to companies in
the form of
without me you might think hmmm alright
that's great
I'm a manufacturer I'm a retailer I'm a
logistics company or I'm a bank why do I
care why you should care because if you
are a traditional company what has set
you apart in the past which might be oh
I've got a big data center and in that
big data center I run some really big
enterprise IT IT I might have been your
competitive advantage in the past for
some of you this might be a slight
burden today because one of the key
things that companies need to be aware
of and that may be is your treasure not
your data center but the data within
that data center and how do you exploit
how do you use how do you make better
decision from that data within your data
center and that often requires the tools
that are available in the public cloud I
don't think your sense of urgency is to
take a work load from A to B and then
save 20% on the way or you name it that
does not necessarily imply a sense of
urgency especially if you think about
companies doing quite well as an average
across the region your sense of urgency
is a different one you want to be
prepared for the future and you want to
be using the tools that your competition
you can use as well and your competition
might be somebody that you have not been
dealing with in the past that might be
that startup company that takes their
credit card goes to the Google Cloud
registers on the portal goes to the
console and within 90
seconds spawns up a thousand node Hadoop
cluster they use it for ten minutes and
then it takes them 60 seconds to shut it
down
that is your competition today at the
end of the month they will find an
invoice on their credit card statement
for twelve and a half minutes of usage
of google cloud this is the environment
that were in today and this is your
sense of urgency whether your startup or
whether you're an established company
you want to stay ahead of the
competition you want to do that with the
latest tools available to you you want
to look at how you work together and be
more collaborative increasing
productivity is everybody's challenged
you want to be at the end of the day
more agile more reactive to changes in
the business ideally you want to be
proactive really and all that as you're
dealing with security threats out there
on the internet you want to do all that
ideally and be more safe and this is
where Google and the cloud can help for
us this region Germany Austria and
Switzerland is one of the key regions on
the planet it's a center of innovation
it's the home of many multinational
companies that have global influence and
this investment that we're making and
this importance is reflected by the
investments we were making and one of
the investments we've announced three
months ago is local computing power is
our data region in Frankfurt which has
dramatically reduced the latency and
opens up new opportunities for
application development and application
deployment within the region and it
helps companies to keep the applications
and data close to their heart
we're completely committed to GDP our
who's busy with GDP are at this point in
time the general data protection
regulation many so are we and we think
this is a blessing so we're taking what
used to be a guidance from the European
Union which was then interpreted
slightly differently from all the Member
States and then if you look at the
states within Germany they might have
had their own preferences we're taking
that into a general regulation which can
help us and which will help us and we're
completely committed to this new
regulation another important thing for
Germany which has an impact globally as
well is our partnership with sa P I've
got sa P here as well as I'm glad to
have them here and it spawns three areas
engineering how we work together to help
the industry it's running sa piece
technology on our Google cloud platform
as well as our partnership around
compliance where s AP helps our joint
customers by monitoring services and
making sure that they are delivered to
the service delivery and quality as
required cloud is used by many companies
across the globe don't worry I'm not
gonna talk about every logo here you
will know most of these logos and you
will probably think T you know some of
those logos they look rather
conservative some of those companies I
didn't know that they were looking at
cloud I can tell you they are the cloud
is real the cloud is there and the cloud
wouldn't be real without our partners
please make sure as you're here to step
by the partners booth and visit them
because they are the ones that take your
opportunities that take your
requirements and they make them
solutions on our cloud platform I'm very
happy
to announce one of our most prominent
examples on stage a retailer one of the
largest retailers in Germany
needless to say one of the largest
retailers on the planet they surf
businesses and they serve consumers and
they have a clear vision on how they
help their customers in their digital
transformation please welcome on stage
the CIO and the chief solution officer
of Metro AG Timo Salceda
[Music]
[Applause]
so good morning everyone I'm happy to be
here thanks for the invitation from from
Google Michel already mentioned what we
are doing and just to give you a bit of
an overview you see on the slide here
because most of you should be familiar
with matrons you you know these blue
boxes everywhere around the major cities
in Germany you might also know they are
which is one of our brands but not a lot
of people actually know how big we are
really are so it's 36 billions business
globally we are serving 35 countries and
our costs are mainly out of the b2b
space so we talk about hotels for
restaurants caterers etc and we serve
them mostly with food but also with
non-food products and it's a global
business as I said we have 150 thousand
employees worldwide and within IT we are
two-and-a-half thousand people with a
large development unit so we have
subsidiaries in Romania in India in
China obviously in Germany so those
would office our headquarters and we
just opened recently an office in Berlin
also to attract talents in that area and
the funny story was in Berlin that we
are on a campus with a couple of other
startups there and one of the guys
approached us and asked how's your
funding doing and actually they did not
obviously know that we are that we are
quite big so so we're doing well
regarding our funding so what are the
challenges and my coaches mentioned we
have obviously the issue that we are
pretty strong when it comes to offline
business so our stores are going really
well but as you know the food sector is
is kind of slow compared to other areas
like clothing books consumer electronics
etc and therefore and we are moving also
obviously into the digital space now so
the digital transformation another
buzzword used within our organization so
and due to the fact that we have these
global operations we have obviously a
couple of massive challenges so
scalability is for us critical because
we are present in countries like India
and just imagine that we're running some
campaigns on mobile devices send output
push measures and push messages etc
which obviously means that millions of
people will approach our services the
scalability is for us really important
the other issue is performance because
we just need to make sure that our users
getting excellent performance out of our
applications and security and you might
have seen in the news that Metro had
also some incidents regarding one a cry
in Russia and Ukraine we handle it quite
quite easily but at the end we are
obviously attracted for some of the
hackers therefore security is one of our
top priorities the other thing I just
mentioned is the digital business and
you see a couple of screenshots about
our actually offering for the digital
space or classical web shops and we
implement them basically completely on
our own solutions that means we're not
using any external software all of our
offerings whether it's back-end
solutions or internal solutions and also
web solutions are implemented with our
own people and obviously we have
challenges like providing the service
globally you see a nice screen shot here
of one of the apps we are running in
China on the bottom right you see that's
one of our flagship stores in France we
have the self scanning devices so these
little devices on the left and there's a
kiosk system called heavy article kiosk
on the right side so and you might
wonder why are we having a webshop
within a store so the name says is
already it's in heavy article kiosk so
if you want to order for example a beer
barrel which is quite heavy you order it
there directly you go to the cashier you
identify yourself with a metro card and
then there's a nice gentleman from our
staff and this gentleman is delivering
the beer barrel directly to your car so
these kind of service you're offering
and in several several stores we are
mainly driven obviously by innovation
innovation about the internal services
so you see logistics is one of the
topics the football fans in the room
might identify one of our customers at
the at the top right so we are serving
obviously this football club mostly with
beer and currywurst and sometimes that's
actually also with shar-pei
if they play against Dortmund mainly and
and obviously also try to serve our
customers when it comes to actually the
touch point with their customers so for
example within a restaurant so we're
providing technology in service there
and the most innovative part is on the
bottom left it's a self checkout service
and just imagine you're having a
scanning device or it's a mobile app you
scan in the products you put it into the
basket and and then you drive this card
into this little device it's a scale so
it weights really what's in your cart
there are cameras on top of it it takes
roughly about 10 seconds and we're doing
is currently in Poland 10 seconds and
you're good to go
no cashier no payment no credit card
it's in there and this just gives you an
impression how innovative you actually
are doing so what's this partnership of
Google all about and obviously we are
very excited about this otherwise I
would not be here on stage and the
scalability topic is one of the major
issues coming back to the example I
mentioned earlier we're having these
huge campaigns running in these big
countries and we also serve in countries
like India and Pakistan just bring an
example and therefore scalability is a
massive topic for us we are very happy
about the unmatched performance of the
Google Network because we serve as I
said customers globally and security is
also very well covered by Google and I
know that Google had a pretty hard time
with our legal people with our
governance people and they did very well
because at the end we managed to finally
sign a contract with Google and are now
able to roll out Google for our digital
business worldwide and be using the
Google cloud platform to make sure that
our customers get excellent service out
of our platform and the other thing
we're doing with Google is obviously
engineering as I said we have a huge
development community with our own
organization this is actually one of the
teams from us in Dusseldorf and we're
just exchanging with Google how
methodology works for example Design
Thinking is one of the major topics
we're currently investing in but we're
also leveraging out for our own
applications the API is provided by
Google so machine learning is relevant
for us
we're doing a lot of natural language
processing voice recognition image
recognition so we are pretty well on
this on this route and therefore using
Google as a technology partner is really
essential for us also to drive our own
applications so and this is obviously
also something that's relevant for us
innovation drives us massively and we
now have obviously use cases like you
see here on the screen where we just
provide to our customer services based
on Google technologies or just imagine
there's a chef and obviously dirty hands
cannot type on computer or any tablet so
I know offer them services like based on
Google homes so that they can order
Metro products directly out of the
kitchen so these are the kind of
services we are providing so very happy
to be a partner of Google enjoy the
collaboration very much and yeah thank
you for attention and have a wonderful
Google cloud summit today we are very
excited about this partnership as well
and we're very excited to be working
with you on your vision I think we've
got to do something about that soccer
club that just came to me I don't think
you've been serving a lot of champagne
lately you know I think that for those I
think it's cologne right for those not
familiar I think the last in the league
right now and they have a little bit of
catching up to do so maybe with some
some initiative we have to think of
there I'm excited to announce a person
next on the agenda who's from our we
call it the office of the CTO and that's
part of the partnership that we have
with our clients
please let me welcome on stage Paul
strong
[Applause]
[Music]
morgen münchen negates good fantastic
that's about the limit of my German
these days it's quite sad I was actually
brought up in a little village called do
any crime on the hähnel alarm star sir
but unfortunately I moved back to
England when I was seven and I had no
one to speak German to so now I have
this accent so firstly welcome I think
right now we live in quite possibly one
of the most exciting times that I can
remember in terms of the evolution of
Technology and how it is intersecting
with business and with life I think we
saw with the example of Metro there is a
real transformation taking place this is
not just about technology allowing you
to do things faster cheaper and more
reliably than you could before this is
not about incremental change absolutely
you can use technology to make it
cheaper faster and more reliable but
technology today is being used to do
things differently fundamentally
differently
and this is what digital transformation
is all about this is not about business
as usual this is not like about
government as usual this is about doing
things differently it's about thinking
about things differently every company
in this world becomes a technology
business it's about writing software
it's about getting intimacy and insight
into your customers in the world around
you this is what the digital
transformation is all about and it's
driven by a set of technology trends
many of them have been evolving over
many years but they've all come together
at this point in time to enable true
transformation and
if you think about cloud for me cloud is
not a destination cloud is a vehicle
that takes us on this digital
transformation journey cloud with the
first time with cloud you can get
technology and particularly the
technology that doesn't differentiate
you as a commodity in the past you have
to buy software you had to buy the
hardware to run it on you had to buy the
people to run the software and run the
hardware now you can make it someone
else's problem so that you can focus on
what differentiates you what makes you
more competitive this is what cloud
allows with mobility you can now engage
with anyone anywhere you know you can
make good guesses as to what they're
doing what they're doing in their lives
you're getting intimacy and from that
intimacy you can get insight and
understanding so you can deliver better
services whether that's monetizing ads
or whether it's allowing people to do
amazing things you see government's who
put applications on phones so that you
know their customers their citizens can
take photographs of potholes in the road
in Malaysia and they automatically end
up on a list of things to be done by the
Ministry of Transport mobility is
changing everything social is changing
everything the interaction model way
people engage with each other is
shifting and changing in some ways we
talk a lot about globalization and we
think about it in terms of industry but
there's a globalization of friendships
my daughter who are one of my four
daughters is 25 she's from England she
met friends online she went partying
with many of them actually in Poland and
now she's moved to Australia where a
whole bunch of them live but this whole
the way people talk to each other way
people engage the way people share
information and trends are driven is
fundamentally shifting and change
IOT gives that same connection that you
see with social and mobile but not with
people but with machines I'm connected
I'm a cyborg did you know that I happen
to be diabetic and I have a constant
flow glucometer plumbed into my arm that
allows my wife 5,000 miles away in the
United States to know that I'm healthy
and I can monitor my eight-year-old
daughter who is also diabetic and if my
wife is a sleeper my daughter goes low I
can give her a call and wake her up so
that there isn't an emergency this
connectedness is allowing us to get more
data and insight and all of that big
data the job of technologists is to turn
that data into insight and understanding
and then act on it to be able to engage
again back through the internet of
things or with mobile this intersection
of all of these technologies is
profoundly changing everything we do in
life and it says that every organization
and every business today is a technology
business your success will be defined by
how you use and consume technology and
your failure or your epitaph on your
gravestone will be how you didn't if you
don't take advantage of it what we see
happening with this technology is
technology is being used it is being
used to undermine the assumptions the
foundations that you build business
models on I'll give you a couple of
examples the first one is a fairly
famous one most of you will be familiar
with the stories of ride-sharing and
things like uber and lyft what's
interesting here is the story of how it
came about
so taxis you know there it's an old
established business and there are
certain barriers to entry to the
marketplace if you want to be a taxi
driver you have to learn your way around
cities because driving with a map in
your lap is kind of dangerous
and you kind of want to know that you
can trust the taxi driver so in London
they have a thing called the knowledge
and you spend three years studying all
the streets in the landmarks around
London and it's quite interesting
actually so these taxi drivers all this
memorization and recall actually turns
them into mutants so it turns out that
when you memorize things so much it
actually makes a part of your brain
bigger physically bigger so the Darwin
in me says that if we look at taxi
drivers for long enough they'll end up
with these enormous heads just like
those aliens that you see in 1950s
science fiction movies but the point is
that these businesses and the underlying
assumptions were predicated on teaching
drivers and validating them through
licensing now with a mobile device it
has GPS it has voice it has maps it can
tell you where to go
you can summon your ride you can see
where it is you can give feedback at the
end so that you get a better idea of the
reputation of the driver than you ever
ever could before this is a fundamental
shift this is technology disrupting
established businesses if you think of
the spare parts business and logistics
3d printing means you don't need
warehouses full of spares anymore you
can print them on demand with 3d
printers and CNC machines at the edge
this disruption is coming to all of us
where technology is being used and says
is that assumption that your model is
built on valid anymore in the face of
technology and when it isn't then
there's risk because the small and
nimble with nothing to lose have access
to the same technologies as the largest
businesses in the world and that is
because of cloud so when we think about
the journey going forward the question
is what does it look like what are the
steps we put it down into four key areas
the first optimize get
the business of delivering IT that
doesn't differentiate you and make it
someone else's problem
make it Google's problem because what
doesn't differentiate you does
differentiate us so that you can focus
on collaboration driving teams to work
together to be more productive and more
effective and through that collaboration
drive innovation and then to accelerate
your business to be able to focus on the
technology that enables insight and
engagement to actually drive new value
new services and to take them to market
and then in doing all of that you need
the right partner we believe we are that
partner to help you take that digital
transformation journey let's quickly
talk about optimize and what's happening
in that space for us Google cloud is a
full suite of products going from the
low level of offering compute network
and storage all the way up to work
collaboration Suites like G suite when
we talk to our customers there's a set
of drivers that we see reliability
security and so forth it's the classic
list that IT want out of infrastructure
Google what doesn't differentiate you
you want to get as infrastructure as a
service I say is infrastructure as a
differentiator for us we believe and our
businesses all of those billion user
businesses have driven us to deliver
better infrastructure more scalable in
fact we build our own servers if we sold
servers we'd probably be the world's
third or fourth largest server vendor
but we don't sell any they're all built
and customized for Google so that we can
deliver services that are more reliable
that are faster and cheaper than we
could in any other way and we were
driven to do that by the growth of our
own business and the opportunity for you
is to take advantage of that it's also
about managing things in a different way
with site reliability engineering is
about taking us to a place when we build
out infrastructure in this new world we
think differently about availability
it's all about resilience and
reliability and it's baking it into
everything that we
the apps in this new world assumed the
infrastructure brakes so you have to
build and design them differently and
you have to manage them differently and
we wrote the book on it something we
shared with the world and I encourage
all of you to actually get the site
reliability engineering book and to have
a read and learn how Google has figured
out at least how to deliver at extreme
scale and with great reliability I
always say one of the amazing things
about Google that you can learn is we
can afford to make the mistakes that you
can't we've been very lucky we have a
very successful business and we've been
able to experiment and learn the lessons
that otherwise would be very expensive
in terms of delivering performance we
have something rather unique Google
actually has a Navy I bet you didn't
know that right
we actually have ships and what those
ships do is they lay cables under the
ocean one of our main differentiators is
actually by having our own physical
network with the fibers that we own
ourselves going across the globe we are
in a position to make your applications
perform and be more reliable than in any
other infrastructure you don't have to
worry about talking with telco providers
for wine connections because we can give
you very very fat fast low latency pipes
across the world so that when you build
applications and run them on Google
Cloud they can talk to each other and
get very very low latency and in fact
today something like 40% of the total
world's Internet traffic goes across
Google's own private network
this is pretty insane by the way when I
joined Google is like insane engineering
crazy numbers we build a lot of our own
networking kit to allow our customers to
take advantage of this we also now have
direct connection capabilities around
the world so you can place your servers
so that they don't have the internet
between them and your services that sit
inside Google's cloud and we've added a
set of regions we talked earlier about
moving into Germany and Frankfurt and
we're moving into
other areas around the world expanding
very very fast all of this is about
giving you unrivaled performance and
scale in fact our investment in
delivering all of this is somewhere in
the region of 30 billion dollars in
terms of a trailing three-year capex
investment this is so that you don't
have to make that investment we invest
in the infrastructure scalable resilient
so that you don't have to do it and we
can deliver it in a way that is very
cost effective and very green and very
sustainable we use technologies like
machine learning and AI to actually
drive down the energy consumption of our
own data centers everything you see in
the services we offer outside we use
inside to enable Google to scale and be
reliable and this is reflected in our
performance numbers you will generally
see that Google is there or thereabout
in terms of providing the highest
performing as well as extremely reliable
and cost-effective services finally I'd
like to briefly talk about security
because ultimately what we hear from our
customers is all of this is great but
without security who really gives a damn
about all of this right it's just table
stakes
but Google it's everything that we think
about our entire stack is optimized for
security we customize you build our own
motherboards we build our own chipsets
we build our own operating systems so
they can be efficient but also so that
we can get rid of all of the unnecessary
components so that people can't attack
them and they can't be compromised so we
end up with a very very secure stack we
even have our own silicon our own chips
that we put in our devices to allow us
to understand their entire history in
doing all of this that security also
results in compliance so with Google
Cloud when we get when we satisfy some
criteria in terms of compliance for
example here in the United States or
whatever it doesn't apply to some subset
of Google Cloud it's all of Google Cloud
and so all of Google Cloud is
essentially homogeneous it looks
same if it's qualified for some criteria
then all of it is and as Michael said
earlier part of that compliance story is
also around gdpr and you know when it
becomes comes to the fore in March next
year we're working very hard both with
our customers and internally to make
sure all of us are ready a couple of
quick areas around security innovation
the first is identity aware proxy now
why would you care about this well
Google's kind of interesting when I work
at Google when I joined Google we
actually don't use VPNs to connect into
Google infrastructure we actually assume
we have a zero trust model and what we
want is fine-grained access to our
applications and services inside Google
so what we do is we actually do
everything through a browser it doesn't
matter where we're the wrong Google's
Wi-Fi or outside on the Internet and
this actually uses a service called the
identity or web proxy that allows us to
get inside Google's infrastructure and
to work with all the applications and
services we need to but with very
fine-grained security and this we now
offer as a service for our customers
secondly another area innovation is the
data loss prevention API which is really
around focusing on managing data making
sure that only the right people can get
at the right data and getting rid of
data or getting it out of sight for the
people who shouldn't be at it and so
what I'd like to do now is to have a
demonstration and we'll talk about DLP
and do that please join me in welcoming
to the stage the bonsoir
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for yes like Paul already
mentioned now with the GDP our coming
next year yeah we certainly need to be
aware of what's in our database if it's
sensitive data or a personal data in our
datasets and as a developer I'm always
worried about that so luckily we now
have that DOP API data loss prevention
API which can help you with that and the
way how it works is you pass in a text
and then as a second argument you
specify some fields where you want to
scan for and these fields can be
passport number credit card number phone
number and then you can scan your data
set whether that whether you connect it
to your data pool you know as a batch or
as a call in real time and you get back
like the data that is sensitive you can
even flag it you can even mask it to
show that I like to show you a demo and
I thought I'd like to create or take a
kind of real live demo here like like I
say a chat application and this is just
a fictional company right it's called
Acme customer support and add a cell and
Veliz hammers that they sell in a world
of warcraft or Skyrim and what's
happening here is like in the chatbox
Angela like this it's the complaining
that the product doesn't work and that
emply asked like okay well what is your
contact number and then here's the thing
this is always what customers do when
there is like an input field they just
enter everything they have like over
here this is my phone number this is my
name this is my last name here's my
credit card number here's my passport
and then at that moment yeah ooh now
that's in our data set that now that can
be in our database but luckily we
implemented the DOP API here so what i'm
doing here is when i en't the chat there
it goes you see it makes a call and
immediately it starts flagging the
sensitive data out so did this data
won't be stored and this jet application
is just a nice UI but
but you can see here is the actual call
that's been made who turns Jason and
that's what you yeah this is how the API
looks like and this is what you can
implement so that's kind of cool
let's have another example here and for
this example I like to make use of the
camera that I have your own stage and I
took here and passport German passport
and then German Bank art and we're gonna
we can make a picture of it and I'll see
if we in real time can yeah
mask the sensitive data now in this demo
just to show you that it works with
these field names this array of fields
that you pass in I can show you the
fields that we're in this case scanning
form so I'm looking here for credit card
number dry string license numbers faces
so pass photo but also specific for
Germany there is a passport field and
there we have it for all kinds of
countries so for example for the
Netherlands we have a PSN number which
is what we put in a Dutch Passport
alright so now let's make a picture and
see what what happens here there you go
now and before you guys think like this
is probably all scripted I like to
welcome Paul back on stage and we can
make a selfie here yes selfie I like
being redacted on selfie this is this
gonna do alright thank you thank you
very much Lee
so I think it's a very cool demo but
what it really shows is the value as we
externalize sets of services and
complicated technologies like machine
learning you are able to make use of
those trivially and simply some of these
in applications and services you see
built in the demos they can be built
very rapidly and very quickly and you
can get value out of them and this
security that we talked about it's
in-depth in everything we do from the
client and chrome and Android all the
way through to GCP at the back end what
I'd like to do now I think you've
already heard from Metro and I think
it's great to hear the real stories of
people to transformation at this point
I'd like to welcome to stage another
customer to share some time with you
talking about how Google cloud has
helped them transform their organization
and their business and to do that
welcome to the stage from Deutsche börse
Sir Thomas Curran
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello good morning
Deutsche Bursa probably none of you
really know much about it but I'll give
you a few things one is if we had a
formula one of marketplaces we'd be
racing in it we do about 200 million
contracts a month in marketplace
transactions if we were a bank we'd also
be in the big boys
we have about thirteen point one
trillion assets under management so we
have the very fast stuff and the very
big stuff and in the middle we have
quite a lot of challenges dealing with a
very complex set of businesses security
was just mentioned I think if anyone in
the room can imagine themselves building
an infrastructure that's more secure
than Google good luck
I'm a Google cloud junkie and one of the
reasons is because I believe it's the
most secure infrastructure you can buy
anywhere that's very important for our
business because of the size but it's
also very important because security
today is not a one-way street it's
something that you have to be able to
count on over time and if you go and
talk to Google and look at their
security infrastructure you'll see why
the best minds the best technology
compliance we obviously have a lot of
rules in our business and implementing
those rules and doing it over time with
a trusted partner is very important but
also we understand flexibility is also
an issue over time compliance changes
because of new regulations and new
things that happen in markets new
instruments disasters 2008 so compliance
is a very big issue and we need a
partner to deal with that and by the way
two years ago
when I brought up Google cloud I think
it's fair to say people laughed me out
of the room say that Google doesn't
understand this business but they do
Google is not the only cloud provider
that we use the reason for that is we
also need to have flexibility in the way
we deliver services and we deliver we
develop software on multiple platforms
so Google gives us a lot of capabilities
to move between those cloud platforms
and in particular what's very important
there some of the new things that were
mentioned here the compute the compute
platform kubernetes in particular so we
have these things that give us multi
cloud capabilities and that's very
important for our business why is that
important what are we doing we're
building a global platform Deutsche
Bursa is in 27 countries across the
world mostly in Europe but also in
United States and Asia and to serve
customers in those countries we need a
scalable and resilient platform to
deliver our business services on top of
that we're building new business
business that relies on it on a cloud
infrastructure for real-time smart data
and analytics those analytics are built
on very new technologies that we deliver
in the cloud and we deliver them via an
API platform and the ecosystem of
trusted FinTech companies that we've
been able to sign up and work with and
it's a growing and if you're in FinTech
please talk to me about it all of that
is new and as we already heard today
multiple times the world is being
digital digitization is important and in
our business developing new digital
business models and delivering new
digital products is very very important
to growing the business here's one
example
it's very concrete we have a big giant
pipeline of real-time data coming out of
our trading infrastructure again 200
million contracts a month those are not
just for derivatives their cash
therefore in exchange there's reference
data by the way we run also the largest
energy trading infrastructure in Europe
we use different technology standards
for instance pub/sub from Google we use
pcap which is a network standard we use
CSV we use XML we use JSON we put all of
those things in different formats into a
data Lake on Google Cloud storage that's
very important because again in the past
flexibility was not a given
you had to structure information to
store it in large infrastructures today
that's changed lot that's changed love
because you have new technologies that
let you then transform that information
Big Data bigquery tensorflow machine
learning to operate in Google Cloud we
use a very great invention from Google
by the way called go language if any of
you have ever tried it I suggested we
use it because Google learned as we
learned that managing large complex
infrastructures you need to have speed
and reliability so we're building our
BOTS and go we're building data marts
than in BigTable and then we're
providing those to customers via our
digital business platform which is guess
what also written in go and has api's
that then customers partners academia
people we never met before can now
consume data from deutsche bursar group
in particular market data from this
public data set based on bigquery we're
doing all that because again it's not
only I'm a Google cloud junkie we're
doing it because we see a growing and
emerging new kind of computing
infrastructure that we believe will
deliver better results will deliver
better security and overtime gives us
the reliability we need to build a
global infrastructure that will help our
business grow thank you google for
having it
let's really appreciate it and we really
appreciate your partnership so this
morning we've talked had customer
examples we've talked a lot about
digital transformation the stages of the
journey notion of optimize get out of
the business of the IT that doesn't
differentiate you next we're actually
going to explore collaboration he says
if the slide will come up so optimize
get out of the business of delivering
the IT that doesn't differentiate and
focus on what does differentiate and
then what you really need to do is to
drive productivity and the environment
that drives innovation that's all about
collaboration and to spend some time
talking to you about that and sharing
where we're going at Google and how you
can take advantage of our work please
welcome to the stage bill hip and Mayer
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
great to be here so you might ask
yourself where does collaboration fit
into the power of the cloud and you know
we talked about AI and we could talk
about transformation services
infrastructure capabilities and all the
things are involved in in being able to
take workloads from your systems in your
environment and it taken advantage of
the leverage the network that we provide
in all those things
why collaboration where does
collaboration fit in it is our belief at
Google that collaboration is the
beginning of this this transformation
process if you think about it
transformation is the end result of a
big idea where the big ideas come they
come from the creative juices and forces
that are happening within your
organization creativity is all about
what creativity begins with engagement
engagement is when one two three and
more people gather together and they
begin to synthesize new ideas one person
has a concept a problem a solution some
thoughts about something but then that's
immediately impacted by the people and
organization around them and ideas come
from everywhere they come from the top
of the organization where we're doing
strategy and thinking out for word they
come from the grassroots of the
organization where in retail stores in
manufacturing plants and across the
business people are coming up with new
ideas new approaches and new ways to
solve problems that has to be
facilitated with an infrastructure in
today's world I'm gonna state the
obvious you're gonna say bill we get it
right things are moving faster if you
look at the innovation cycles in today's
world if you examine the product life
cycle and the ability to bring new
products to market you no longer have
twenty years to bring a new BMW to
market you no longer have twenty years
to reconstruct new life science
approaches or think about new
transportation logistics solutions or to
rethink digital communications across
the globe what you must do is you must
shrink that lifecycle you must
accelerate
creation and the only way to do that we
believe is to be equipped with a proper
set of tools to do so
the Google suite that we have
constructed and the tools that we would
invite you to use are built around this
ability to gather people together in
real time to collaborate to come up with
the big idea which is going to lead to
the transformation that you're looking
to do so we have a set of tools that
allow you to create and to rise that
level of creation instead of being an
individual activity but to make it a
group activity where you're working in
real time we provide tools that allow
you to connect connect in real time
exchange ideas and be able to be able to
riff off each other and synthesize new
thoughts and new areas we do that with
the ability to quickly search and access
content in one place held in Google
Drive and then of course we have to give
you the control the security the
compliance the DLP capabilities to be
able to protect that content so that you
can be compliant with things like gdpr
and when you do it there's an impact PwC
adopted the Google Apps orgy suite
platform several years ago they rolled
it out worldwide and they saw dramatic
impact in terms of their productivity if
you think about the world that they live
in their consultants are working every
day both internally and externally to be
able to try to advise on financial
issues tax issues in a variety of other
consulting areas what they have found is
that by being able to reduce the amount
of travel they have through Google
Hangouts and being able to connect
real-time through collaborative document
editing and inviting both the customer
and the suppliers that they're involved
with into the conversation they're
finding that they're able to get to
things things done faster and the
ability to be able to connect in real
time those things have led to real
savings in a study that they did they
came back and said that on average they
are saving nine hours per week per
employee and they have a lot of
employees
that's real numbers and the financial
people love
the impact of that but why can't we just
use the tools we've been using for years
to accomplish the same thing our
argument and our platform says that the
way of collaboration that our
competitors are offering is really an
old-school style of methods they haven't
really changed fundamentally the way you
work in fact I often talk to c-level
executives that have adopted the
competitor platform and I asked them
this one question
what are you doing different today now
that you've adopted the latest from your
competitor and how is that transform the
way you work and how has that
accelerated your ideation platform and
in every case they say well bill that's
not what we were about we wanted to
eliminate the impact of change
management on an organization we didn't
really want to change anything we liked
the way we were working and I'm like
really is that what you want to do you
want to just work the way you've been
working for 20 years where an individual
creates a document or a spreadsheet or a
presentation and then they send it out
in email as an attachment as a way to
collaborate and be able to exchange
ideas if you were going to come up with
the top 10 vacation list ideas in a
matter of minutes would you get into a
document and list the top 10 and then
send it out to 10 of your colleagues and
wait for them to reply no you would
actively engage with them in real time
most likely in a conference room or in a
Google Doc and say let's come up with
the top 10 quickly and when everybody is
typing at the same time and they're all
interacting in a collaborative way what
happens is you begin to raise the ideas
quickly you begin to collaborate and
have visual inspection of what other
people are doing and now what you can do
is you can avoid the need to replicate
what greg has put down so Greg and I are
collaborating Tom and I are
collaborating Alexandra and I are
collaborating and I can quickly see they
don't like Cancun Mexico
they prefer nice or or Malaga Spain to
be able to do vacation that's their
preference they're Europeans and I don't
have that experience now I do live in
London now which has been a really
eye-opening experience and I'm really
enjoying it
all right and then the most important
thing that I really love about the suite
is the ability to connect in real time
the reality is is that we don't have to
wait for the Thursday afternoon meeting
that's scheduled for one hour because
all meetings must go an hour that's just
the rule of meetings right that's not
the case when I can have an idea or
inspiration and I can literally reach
out to Joe and Karen and say can you
join me on a hangout for five minutes
and let's walk through this concept of
this idea and when I ping them and they
come back to me and they they say yep
I'm available and we get on a hangout in
five or ten minutes we can move the idea
forward in a way that a meeting on
Thursday afternoon at three o'clock
would not do so the ability to
instantaneously reach out click of a
button and connect in real-time is a
powerful capability and that's what
we're doing and then lastly and you're
gonna hear a lot more about this is the
application of artificial intelligence
to this environment AI in its simplest
form is really about observing patterns
and then be able to recognize the
outcomes they're associated with those
patterns and then being able to do
something that's predictive and being
able to actually look it forward I think
of it like this if I asked you to be a
diving judge at the next Olympics how
qualified are you today probably not
very well a qualified I'm not but if you
sat with a Olympic judge expert and
watched a hundred dives you'd be a
little bit better what if you watched a
thousand dives 10,000 dives $100,000.00
million dives we are literally taking
samples from a billion people that are
simultaneously using our products and
we're able to look at what they're doing
and predict what's next and one of the
great examples of that is it is
expounded upon an explorer in sheets if
you regularly get a data set maybe it's
a point of sale data and you're trying
to ask a simple question like ok Google
show me the highest profit product that
happened that that was sold during the
months of September October and November
across the different states in Germany
and illustrate the raised to the top the
most
duck Tavor the most the best margin
product during that period you don't
want to have to write the formula that
does that but Google has been watching
the way experts analyze data and from
thousands and millions of examples they
can actually we can actually predict
what's next and offer some insight
immediately when you open up so all you
have to do is hit the explore button and
now I have a set of graphs and charts
and pivots that are already available to
me to be able to examine and I can do
that without having to do any work
whatsoever and then I can start to ask
questions and Google will actually write
the formula for you so we're doing a lot
of work in AI and that's only one
example of many x' in terms of what
we're doing to be able to apply
artificial intelligence machine learning
to your work as you collaborate so let's
not just take my word for it but what
I'd like to do is invite a customer to
come up and talk a little bit about what
they're doing in the application of G
suite so I'm happy to invite Alex
Pullman from V spawn to come and share
his experience
[Applause]
so yeah welcome good morning from my
side
I'm really happy proud to tell you that
we have gone Google this year and we
have gone G sweet it's a digital
transformation at fist man with G sweet
feet man is a traditional family-owned
business and we are producing heating
boilers cooling systems and also some
industrial systems our revenue is about
2.2 billion euros and we have 12,000
employees all over the world so we
started our digital transformation and
around 2015 because we saw our there new
business models came up new competitors
also a company of alphabet nest I've
also on my slides they came up and they
are taking our core business and also
our thoughts about new businesses so
what we have done we are spread out a
strategy for digital transformation in
the most project called the future
workplace so the future workplace it's
more about at the very beginning it's
more about evaluation of a platform
solution so we came from an IBM nodes
infrastructure we have run IBM notes for
at least 22 years and yeah you know it
is a big grown infrastructure so our
talk or our priorities also lay on the
usability because if you want to use
your software and and you'll also want
to users use your software you have to
get them on an easy software
functionality was also an aspect also
the IT security all of you heard about
the security layer of Google this is
maybe also one of the reason why we
choose Google because we think it is the
most secure platform for us to use so
the integration part and also the costs
were also prioritized in the evaluation
at the end we decided to move to G suite
and you're really happy we have now a
workplace that is easily accessible on
any device at any place at any time both
mentioned our people should and
anytime any place they should easily get
together they should create ideas we
have no more flexibility more security
more team collaboration and also more
transparency at the same cost so our
main achievements like we have started
the global rollout for Jesus with this
year in June and we have an average
1,500 people each month coming to G
suite we have migrated them 15% of our
users are using bring-your-own-device
services just imagine if like 1200
people spent 10 minutes each day in
their private life with their work
environment that are like 200 hours a
day your company will save 1.7 million
emails doesn't need to be archived
anymore
NIV notes we had just 100 megabyte space
left in your in milk's no the storage is
unlimited it's great so and everyone
uses to factor on technification so
everyone can reach his work benefits
from everywhere and you just needs to
get a smartphone all of his trouser and
say yes I am so 4500 Google meets are
done each month so yep you're heard it's
just six months ago we started the
rollout and it's it's pretty increasing
this number also it's like four thousand
five hundred if you think for for four
thousand five hundred if for one one
Google need of one hundred it's just a
business trip you can save as a company
you will save around 45 to 50 business
trips every month and your people could
engage everywhere everywhere at any time
so the last part is all about
collaboration we don't send any
documents anymore it's all like we share
it and collaborate in one document and
all the stuff I really like and I really
would like to thank all all of my team
colleagues and also our
partner closed verdict for the great
support we had during the migration but
I'm pretty sure that this is just the
beginning of a big change at our future
workplace and I'm really looking forward
to all the new cool stuff that will come
from Google in the future thank you guys
thank you Alex for sharing really
appreciate that so we've talked about
optimize about leveraging the power of
Google infrastructure Network and data
center services hopefully you've got
some insight into why collaboration is
so important to us what I'd like to do
next is take you to the next level which
is accelerate in acceleration it's
really about learning and growing and
harnessing the power of Big Data machine
learning and technologies like that that
will really help you be able to move
faster and to move better so with that
I'd like to introduce my friend and
colleague Greg Dimas Shelley who's going
to talk a little bit about accelerate
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks everyone
I'm really excited to talk about this
section of the talk because as Paul said
going into cloud 2 just shift a little
bit of capex to OPEX or save 5 or 10%
really misses the opportunity that it
provides you the opportunity to not just
save money not just to affect your cost
side of the business but to drive new
business and the best way to think about
that is to think about it in terms of
how do you get value out of data think
about it as companies we have become
digital pakrats we store ever increasing
amounts of data by some estimates we'll
have a hundred and sixty-three
zettabytes of data per year by 2025 I
had to Google what does zettabyte is by
the way just in case you don't know I
believe it's a trillion gigabytes and
why is it that we're doing that the
cloud has made it possible
it took store a petabyte of data 10
years ago you had to get a robotic tape
archive you had to spend millions of
dollars on special machinery now for a
penny a gigabyte a month you can store
every bit of data from your factory or
your business or your retail operation
so the problem is shifted from how do I
store that data to how do I find the
needle of value in that haystack of data
now the way this works for most of us
today is Big Data
right that's the answer big data
and we know something about that at
Google because most of what is in big
data today dates to research papers that
Google published ten years ago big data
is built on a foundation of work that we
did within Google and we went through
this pattern which is we build these big
data systems we run them in production
the data grows by a factor of ten we
have to re our Kotak the storage system
and the result is if you look at most
data big data projects within
enterprises today they're not achieving
the results that they promised and why
is it it's because if you look at where
you actually spend your dollars in your
time it's not on getting insights you
spend way too much time on building
maintenance logging backup disaster
recovery
oh no the data is ten times as big let
me rebuild my sharding system nobody
enjoys doing that yet we do it time and
time again you spend too much time
taking care of the machinery and not
enough time actually understanding the
data and again we know this is the case
because we went through this at Google
we went through this exact same pattern
we built data systems we thought they
were great the data got too big we had
to rebuild them and we realized we had
to have a better way we had to have a
different way to think about Big Data
so we said about building out an
entirely new set of data and analytics
products around the simple idea of
reversing this ratio of inverting the
amount of time you spent taking care of
the system and the amount of time you
actually spent getting insights so
across our entire data portfolio you
will see products built natively for the
cloud where all of the work of scaling
and infrastructure and management and
even DBA is taken care of for you and
we've also gone one step further because
we also realized at Google that
traditional batch analytics aren't good
enough the days when you could have a
weekly report of your business as and
call that acceptable if you're a
retailer you want to know what's
happening today
not what happened two weeks
go if you're a manufacturer you want to
know that you're having production
problems today not on a quarterly report
when it's too late to do anything about
it so we built our systems around the
notion that batch and streaming are the
same thing that it should be as easy to
get real-time insights as it is to get a
daily or weekly or quarterly business
report and so when you look across our
entire data portfolio whether it's
bigquery which is a data analytics
warehouse in the cloud literally upload
a petabyte of data write a sequel query
done no DBA no sharding nothing to set
up or data proc which lets you take your
existing hadoop clusters bring him in
the cloud and get out of the business of
managing the hadoop infrastructure or
pub/sub and dataflow which you heard
about from our customers using that to
transform the way you ingest data in
real time what all these products have
in common is they get you out of the
drudgery of maintaining the machinery
and they let you focus on the fun part
I know of no data analytics professional
who got into it because they like
writing sharding systems do what's the
fun part the understanding the analytics
of data and we see this having an impact
on customers Spotify when they join
Google if you talk to their execs they
will tell you the number one reason that
they wanted to use Google was to give
them a competitive advantage in data
think about it every time you skip a
song or you play a song or you search
for a song and Spotify that's data that
helps them predict that next perfect
music for you or in the banking industry
Lloyd's where they say they literally
went from 96 hours to 30 minutes in
terms of their ability to go from an
event happening in the market to them
being able to make a decision based on
that now what's the next step of this
sure we can build data warehouses you've
heard mentioned several times this
notion of machine learning and
artificial intelligence and we really
think that is the next step it's the
next evolution in how you do data and
analytics
and to prove just how much we believe in
it our CEO sundar pichai has said that
this is a core transformative way where
we're rethinking everything we're doing
and that is literally true at Google
there is not a project or a product
inside Google that isn't being rethought
in terms of machine learning and
artificial intelligence if you think
about the consumer side every way that
you interact with Google now has an AI
or machine learning component whether
it's your Android smartphone and the way
it does speech recognition or
autocorrection
or how many of you have used Google
photos and typed birthday party clown
and found a picture from three years ago
of your child's birthday party when
you've had a clown come in or when
you've used Gmail as Bill talked about
where you've had an automatic reply
generator all of these are built on the
notion of artificial intelligence and
machine learning
now it's reasonable ask why I mean
Google has smart programmers can't we
couldn't we have just done this
ourselves without using ml and I think
it's it's important to think about why
ml is so transformative ml lets us solve
problems that we don't know how to solve
think about when you learned your first
language unless you have fairly unusual
parents I don't think they handed you a
grammar book in a dictionary but that's
what we do as programmers we teach our
computers with grammar books and
dictionaries you learned your first
language by being exposed to it by
example your family had a dog your
parents said dog you saw the dog
literally the chemistry in your brain
changed and you learned that that piece
that animal was a dog ml allows us to
take that same technique learn by
example not by rote and apply it to
business problems think about your
factories your customer data your sales
data where there's hidden value and
connections in your data that you're not
taking advantage of ml and AI lets us do
that so we've built a complete platform
around AI and ML at the bottom is all
that same infrastructure
that you heard about earlier the network
to compute the storage because at the
end of the day ml is a real big data and
compute problem on top of that we build
platforms libraries and tools tools that
let you take your business data and
train your own models without having to
worry about how to scale them or how to
deploy them or how to manage them and at
the top we've taken those very same
services that we offer consumers
services that help build systems that
see here speak listen and we've given
those to you by a api's so you don't
even have to be able to spell ml in
order to build systems that can see here
speak and that lets you match the tool
for the job if you are an ml researcher
and you want to be on the cutting edge
of defining how machine learning works
you can use our open source sdk
tensorflow if you're a data scientist in
your company you can use cloud ml engine
to build and train models using
tensorflow but without having to get
into the details of how you build and
scale the infrastructure and if you're
an application developer you can use a
simple API to build vision speech text
hearing directly into your applications
to give you an example of that I want to
show you an example of using those
perception those vision api's inside a
real application so to do that I'm gonna
have Lea come back up and she's gonna
show you an application that actually
knows how to see hear and speak Lea Lea
[Applause]
thank you correct I'm actually very
excited to show the vision API to you
because yeah I'm not a data scientist
I'm an app developer so I can still play
around with machine learning and I don't
need to train my own models no it's pre
trained its pre trained by Google so I
can just use it I can just make an API
call and I pass in an image and usually
you upload an image in a cloud storage
bucket and then I make a vision API call
and the vision API can detect the the
photo and it can
see landmarks it can see persons it can
see objects it gives you all that
information back OCR detection
it's very nice so that is something I
like to show you today I created over
the weekend simple app where I uploaded
two pictures here I uploaded a photo of
a landmark and a photo of a person so
let's have a look into the landmark
picture first now I saw for this
presentation today my co-workers they
they made this photo and they say it's
Munich but yeah I was actually wondering
is this indeed Munich or did they just
take a normal picture from an other
beautiful European city and put that in
the slide deck so what I did is I made a
screenshot of it and I uploaded it into
a bucket and then I checked it with the
vision API the fishing API first gives
me back like all our information okay
that can be handy if you're a designer
and maybe you want to dynamically create
built your page and you have a dark
background and you don't want to have a
dark photo on it so corner information
could be handy but it also recognized it
is indeed a landmark it recognized this
is this is a city it gave me back a
latitude and a longitude coordinate and
with that I can plot it on a Google map
so that is what I did and yes it's
indeed Munich and to be very precisely
it's actually in the marienplatz I
pronounced it correctly so yeah that's
kind of impressive I thought that's cool
what else it did recognize some labels
of what it did see and yeah and I
translated it it's in English but I
connected it to the Translate API so
that I get the labels now back in German
and it tells me yeah it's a it's a it's
a tower it's a major Pole I'm 86 percent
sure it's a is that that's the
confidence level umm the confidence
level says I'm 85 percent sure it's a
city so that's probably correct and it
also as the OCR detection so it detected
like the welcome in
unique okay now let's let's do the same
example again but with a person and I I
picked a Dutch guy but you guys might
know him as well all right yeah I
thought this was pretty impressive that
the vision API did because the the
labels that it gave me back it actually
recognized this is a soccer player it's
eighteen eighty-three percent sure this
is a soccer player and I thought that's
pretty impressive because I don't see
any soccer balls or no footballs here on
this picture I just see some green grass
but that could be any other sport as
well so like the vision API did
understand like yeah that's a soccer
player it's definitely a player has
something to do with sport I see grass I
see team sport so that's cool but what
the vision API did not do is it did not
have facial recognition it did not tell
me who this person actually is but we're
Google right and we know what other
pages have what other pages on the
internet make use of this photo and
based on that we can also get some
entities and here it says it's actually
our in Robin and it is from the Bayern
Munich team and this picture was made in
Wembley station and it had something to
do with the European Cup that's pretty
cool now now obviously this is like just
a simple demo right but you can imagine
that when you want to use this in a
real-life use case let's say you have a
hotel website and you you you paid your
photograph to make pictures of these
hotel rooms you don't want other other
websites other hotel websites to steal
your pictures right so you could use the
vision API for example to detect what
other websites are making use of your
pictures another example could be in in
real estate where you make a photo of a
house and it immediately
yeah sent you to the website after house
listing and says like yeah this house is
for sale
our customers are doing that or maybe in
finance you have like lots of documents
with a lot of text in there can be
handwritten text can be type text and we
use the OCR detection to get out all the
text out of the documents so there are
lots and lots of examples here and this
is why I'm so excited about it
I forgot it back to Gregg thank you
Thank You Lee it was really great to see
so many different api's brought together
in one simple to use application now
that's what we're building at Google I
think it's really useful to hear what
customers are doing with it with ml and
AI and so I'm really pleased to bring
onstage a customer who knows something
about machine learning and how to turn
it into business value she's the
co-founder of one of Europe's most
exciting new startups dealing with
customers is interesting as Porsche and
she did all this while building out her
bachelor's degree in e-commerce please
join me giving a warm welcome to
Michele's katulski from bought friends
Michele
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone so I'd like to
start with a little story there are many
companies out there that people crave to
work for and I believe that Porsche is
maybe one among these generations y&z
are becoming older and ready to enter
business world
it becomes more and more natural to them
to inform themselves about career
opportunities not only by a website or
email but simply on social media such as
writing facebook Messenger all right so
that's the Jobson courier facebook
Messenger and what we can see here is
that someone is asking questions
regarding internships at Porsche alright
after checking the requirements he
unfortunately sees that he doesn't
really fit them but however he asks for
more details on dual studies all right
he gets led to integrated map view and
he can check on all the offers on dual
studies so that is really really easy he
instantly receives all the answers he
wants so the special thing here is that
there's actually no real employee riding
back but this cute robot here on the
right and it's a chat bot and he's the
first chat bot in the automotive
industry instantly answering questions
regarding job offers internships dual
studies etc by using Google's natural
language processing service dialogue
flow and just last week we've been
nominated or no actually we won the
human resources Excellence Award in HR
tech & data with this product so what we
do thank you
thank you very much so what we do at
BOTS friends is we create conversations
over messaging platforms but also voice
assistance with the help of artificial
intelligence so our goals are to meet
higher customer expectations on 24/7
availability and also to establish
messaging platforms as a new way of
communication since we spend 90% of our
time on email and messaging platforms
and since the time we spend there has
actually surpassed the time we spend on
social media and we know that Facebook
Messenger has reached over 1.3 billion
users so that's quite impressive but now
why did we choose the Google cloud
platform to develop such an innovative
product so obviously one of the first
reason is we already talked about this
today the Google cloud platform is super
secure and for companies such as Porsche
this is really really crucial we're also
using all the amazing natural language
API is provided by Google such as a
translation API for a company such as
Porsche it is important to reach all
their potential applicants because we
know that people with different
backgrounds cultures perspectives are
definitely contributing to the company's
success and enabling we can enable
conversations with everyone regardless
of language and origin we are also able
to run adn test on the App Engine which
is so crucial for our MVP approach so by
distributing the traffic on different
chatbots we can see which one is
performing the best and which one is the
one we should actually further develop
and most importantly we are able to
scale up automatically with the App
flexible environment so we can the chat
BOTS can handle endless conversations at
the same time and our developers are
able to focus on what to do you the best
write the code instead of being busy
balancing the loads
alright so after we launch that product
we've seen amazing results the great
service Porsche provided has led to an
increased engagement over 100% and a
reduced workload by over 25
so employees at Porsche were actually
able to focus on more complex requests
after the launch we are planning to use
the PostgreSQL database to enable
creating user profiles so we can offer
subscriptions to job vacancies so
Porsche fans will always stay up to date
whenever the dream job comes up and last
but not least we want to use a sentiment
analysis API by Google to enable human
handovers so whenever a conversation
escalates let's say the the customer is
not happy with the chat bot or the
conversation is unsatisfied we can just
easily direct them to a real employee to
escalate the conversation the last thing
I have to say if you want to hire the
best people provide them with a great
service and with the Google cloud
platform we've been able to develop such
an innovative product thank you very
much and have a great day
thanks so much Michelle thank you so
much it's just a such a great example
again of tying together all these
machine learning capabilities in a way
that really makes a difference so that's
really just a snapshot of what we try to
do to help you accelerate your business
I could have talking about application
development or so many different ways
but I really do think at the end of the
day we can help you get more value out
of what really is the most valuable
thing you have as someone said earlier
it's the data in your data center that
matters not the data center itself and
so we really think that we can help you
by building out a set of products to let
you find value out of that data so now I
want to turn over to the next section of
the today which is to talk about how you
build a partnership relationship
building a relationship with a cloud
provider isn't just a short-term
relationship it's a long-term one and
you want to have somebody who's in there
with you every step of the way
so to talk about partnership and the
role that we think we can play in that
please welcome Tom gray from Google to
talk about that
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Gregg and thank you all for
coming I'm really really excited to be
here I think this is an extremely
exciting time and I'm here to talk to
you a little bit about partnership we
believe that customers are looking for
something new they're looking for new
technologies they're looking for new
business platforms new business models
they're looking for a new place to do
new things but they're also looking for
a new partner a new partner with a new
approach over the course this
presentation we've looked at the
different aspects of digital
transformation we've talked about how
you optimize your business we've talked
about how you divest the parts of the IT
organization and technologies that
aren't differentiating to you we've
talked about how you collaborate we've
talked about how use collaboration to
accelerate and to drive innovation in
your organization and we've talked about
how you use data and you can use data to
differentiate your business at Google we
believe we have one of the foremost
platforms to allow you to do those
things we believe that it's at the
cutting edge in terms of capability in
terms of reliability in terms of
security but we also believe that that
is not enough we believe that to be
successful you also need a partner a
partner that understands the journey but
also a partner that understands the
destination a Google I'm proud that we
have 18 years of innovation behind us
and I'm confident that we have many more
ahead of us in that time we've had a
chance to build some of the leading
platforms for mail some of the leading
platforms for search for mobile heck
we've even got to build self-driving
cars
we've heard the chance to try some
things that really many people only
dream of and we've also had the chance
to frankly make some mistakes that
really you could afford to make and
that's what we want to bring to this
partnership we want to bring and we want
to share that learning want to share
that experience at Google we have a
saying focus on the user and all else
will follow we want to build a platform
that focuses on you we want to build a
platform that's flexible a platform
that's open we want to build a platform
that has easy-to-understand customer
friendly billing we want to understand
to build a platform that enables you to
build and to run the applications you
want to run but also the applications
that you need to run we want to put you
in control of your IT to give you some
examples of how we're doing that I want
to talk about our sustained usage
billing so I sustained usage discounts
as a scheme whereby the more you use of
our cloud the less we charge you per
unit we want to make billing simple and
so with sustained usage discounts those
discounts are applied automatically you
don't have to do anything you just use
the cloud and we automatically work out
what you should be discounted and we
apply that discount on your behalf
without you needing to lift a finger we
also want to make it flexible so we
offer that sustained usage discount
without any kind of commitment up front
on your part whatsoever so it's a simple
it's a flexible it's a customer centric
model for billing we feel we're also
extremely committed to openness and to
open standards Google as the company was
born on the internet and the internet
was born of open standards and it's
thrived as a result we are deeply deeply
committed to open
we're deeply committed to allowing you
to avoid vendor lock-in vendor lock-in
kills innovation vendor lock-in kills
innovation because it doesn't allow the
best technologies to win and lastly
people as I said before we have some
amazing people in Google and some
amazing people that really had the
chance to build some really amazing
things and we want to bring these people
to you we want you to work together with
these people build the next generation
of crazy cool stuff on the internet and
you might say that's great
crazy cool I love it that's kind of cool
that's great but come on Tom what about
everything else we understand we need to
run that as well we need to make it easy
to bring new stuff but we also need to
make it easy for you to bring your
existing applications in your existing
investments on to our cloud as well go
everybody CIOs are moving to the cloud
to save money but they're coming and
they're finding better security better
reliability better flexibility we need
to make it easy for you to bring those
applications to our cloud well we also
want to make sure that when you bring
those applications to the cloud we also
make it easy for you to migrate and to
also take advantage of the new services
that you find their surfaces like the
DLP the data loss prevention API
services like cloud spanner we want to
enable you to migrate and into modernize
and we know that we need to invest in
the people and the processes and the
tools to allow you to do that and one
example of that is our support for
Windows
I hope here everybody would accept and
agree that our platform is an amazing
place to run Linux it's an amazing place
to run open-source workloads there's
also a lot of windows out there right
when he turn able people to run there as
well so we've made investments in things
like supporting images for Windows
Server many different flavors of Windows
Server many different flavors of sequel
server as standard images we support
hosting Active Directory so that you can
extend your on-premise Active Directory
domain controller into the cloud for
Windows developers we want you to be
able to use the same familiar powerful
tools that you're used to using so in we
now support Visual Studio you can
develop your applications in Visual
Studio and you can easily deploy them to
our cloud the cloud SDK supports over a
hundred different commandlets for the
Windows PowerShell to enable to use the
tools that you're familiar with to work
in our environment and one of the areas
we've made the biggest investment is in
people we know we need to bring people
to this partnership to help you to be
successful people like our customer
engineering and our solution
architecture teams experts who can work
with you to build and design and
architect your applications to get the
best out of our cloud people like the
amazing engineers who sit in our support
organization first-class Google
engineers who enjoy deep relationships
with our software engineering and our
site reliability engineering teams so
that when things go wrong and things
will occasionally go wrong we can get
you up and running as fast as we
possibly can people like our office of
the CTO seasoned industry professionals
with deep technical expertise and a
background in different verticals who
can work with customers who doing some
of the largest most audacious migrations
to the cloud migrations we're deep
technical expertise and domain expertise
are vital to be successful
people like our customer liability
engineers taking the lessons we've
learned with site reliability
engineering running those 1 billion user
applications keeping those up and
running on the Internet
people who can work with you to bring
the same level of resilience and
security to your applications so you can
build applications that stay secure that
stay saleable that stay available under
the most extreme of conditions and
lastly open source we have a lot of
experience with open source and we can
leverage that experience to help you
with your open source packages be that
on our cloud we'll be that on premise so
to finish I just wanted to talk through
an example of this and a great example
of this is Conrad
Conrad's a 90 year old family-owned
company and about 20 years ago they made
a very smart investment and he starts to
invest in e-commerce and today Conrad is
one of the leading electronics suppliers
both in physical stores but also on the
internet they're now working with Google
to move more and more of those systems
into our cloud their IOT platform runs
on Google's cloud and integrates with
Google assist they have moved 5,000 of
their employees to our G suite platform
to allow them to better collaborate to
allow them to be empowered and a safe 90
percent with paperwork in the process
which is pretty cool but lastly and most
importantly of all they're working
collaboration with us to explore new
business models to explore new
possibilities and to test out the
bleeding edge of what we're making
available and I would urge you to go and
check out their booth they have a very
cool booth downstairs so go say hi to
the folks from Conrad and hear a little
bit more about the int platform so in
that I hope I've given you a bit of a
flavour of how we're working in
partnership with you and we believe in
openness and we believe in bringing
people and bringing our expertise
I think it's an extremely exciting time
to be a technologist I'm excited I hope
you're real excited too and with that
I'm going to hand back to Michael thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yeah so we spent the last hour
and a half I'm talking about four
subjects four very important subjects on
your journey in making the digital move
optimize focus on the things that
differentiate you get rid of some of the
things that you shouldn't do collaborate
I think that's pretty obvious we want to
make sure we get more productive work
better together engage and innovate and
look at the things of the future
accelerate look at things like complex
data analytics machine learning and AI
and do that with a partner that cares
the future of the cloud is now it's not
if it's when and when is now I want to
leave you with an overview of what you
can experience this afternoon there
gonna be many sessions and four
different tracks and you're ready to
choose there will be plenty of fools
outside from our partners as well as a
startup booth out there as well as a
booth that says our can ask an architect
where you'll meet with some of our
technical experts and you can talk
through architectures some of you have
already started I've been curious to
share experience on the hashtag Google
summit Munich and I want to leave you
with a little assignment for the
afternoon take one of the opportunities
you have in mind one of the business
opportunities you have in mind and take
this opportunity with you into the
sessions that you'll follow this
afternoon and think about how does this
session and what I'm hearing how does
that apply to my opportunity and make
sure you walk out of here today with
something that you're gonna do different
tomorrow that is going to help you in
fulfilling this idea that said I release
you into the afternoon and I look
forward to seeing you again at our
cocktail reception at 6:15 thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]